e
e e
thank you Mr chair um yes we have three
committee members who are not here today
and so we have um for representative
Ryan we have representative Timothy
Horan we have representative Joan Hamlet
here for aan Kelly and we have
representative Heath Howard here for
Tommy Hoy thank you um for joining us
today thought I was loud enough to it
is first order of business is the uh
Senate Bill uh
547 chair recognizes representative Veil
for
motion thank you Mr chair I make a
motion of a to pass as on this bill okay
do I have a
second rep by representative Derby do
you wish to speak on your motion oh well
uh
we can actually we probably should uh
pass on the speaking on it after the
amendment uh chair uh there recognizes
representative Darby for an amendment
thank you Mr chairman um I'd like to
make an um a motion to amend uh Senate
Bill 547 with Amendment
2024 D 1772 H do I have a second repres
representative Veil we do
second seconded by representative Vale
uh would you like representative Darby
to speak on the amendment um yes thank
you Mr
chair um during the uh hearing on Senate
Bill
547 um during the questions we learned
that the term historic preservation uh
project was not
defined um and that the intent was not
to increase increase the scope of the
funding um that for uh lchip
projects um in subsequent conversations
um uh with the executive director we
learned that um the term easement
interest which is where uh which
included the new term historic
preservation project is used to define
uh the um the projects that can be
funded by elip and therefore this um in
increased the scope of what elip would
fund which was not the intent um and
based on the recommendation from the
executive director um I'm submitting
this amendment which simply removes the
term historic preservation project from
the easement interest definition in the
bill you wish to speak on your second to
the
amendment my colleague has covered the
points
uh uh chrisy uh we is there a uh we
we're missing a uh green sheet for the
if you could help us before we take a
vote uh just I have a question of the of
the director uh you've reviewed this
with
the with representative Darby and you
have any issues with it
we going to hold up for a second while
we we get the Green Sheet which
is without it there's no proof that you
voted
yeah uh thank you
we live by paper
alone all
right on the uh motion on of uh to adopt
the
amendment uh with Amendment uh
H will the clerk please call the
role representative harb yes
representative gold yes
representative Horgan yes clerk votes
yes representative Healey yes
representative
wolf representative MCU yes
representative Donnell yes
representative dun yes representative
Veil yes representative run yes
representative Hamlet yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
Howard yes representative lontine yes
representative
lit representative organ yes and the
chair
yes 20 to zero motion passes thank you
consent that's on the amendment oh
excuse me there yet so too
fast all right on a to pass as a ended
you wish to speak to your motion
representative should
fail this bill is important it has
several requirements that needed to be
clarified um and we were able to amend
the bill so that the scope of the
program did not change and so with that
I just ask my colleagues to vote on to
pass as amended with me thank
you you wish to speak to your second
nothing further thank you Mr chair
anyone else wish to speak on the on the
motion of V to pass as
amended seeing none the clerk please
call the rooll yes thank you very much
representative harp yes representative
gold yes representative organ yes clerk
votes yes representative Healey yes
representative wolf yes representative
MCU yes representative Donnelly yes
representative dun yes representative
Vale yes representative run yes yes
representative Hamlet yes representative
Simpson
yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
Howard yes representative lontine yes
representative LoveIt yes representative
organ yes and the clerk I mean the chair
cler yes okay 20 to zero unanimously
passed no for
for consent
yes that being done
this hearing on
uh this bill 547 sign a bill it's
closed then we open the hearing
on on Senate Bill
431 CH Rec recogniz representative mck
thank you Mr chairman I'll move ought to
pass on Senate Bill
431 31 uh do I uh here a second second
by representative harb this is uh we'll
vote we I'll be open the floor this
we'll open the floor to
Amendment rep representa representative
wolf you wish to speak
thank you Mr chairman I'm going to pass
out an
amendment hopefully everybody has gotten
this on the committee by
email I'm finishing an eighth
year in the
legislature and I have never been quite
so conflicted on a bill
but I have come to a decision on this
thing because I
believe in preserving the
environment for future
Generations I know that there have been
a lot of threats if we don't do X then Y
is going to
happen
and I can't take a chance with those
threats
so I'm offering
Amendment 1598 or
it's a good
compromise and I underline and tsize and
bold the word compromise this bill
started out at 500
feet the Senate came and said 200
feet and we're not going to compromise
on that do we have a leak in the ceiling
we do I'm getting wet right here I just
thought all right maybe maybe there's a
message and I'm going to let you
interpret what the message might be I
just thought you were
sweating no Andy when I make up my mind
I don't
sweat yeah don't yeah otherwise you may
not finish your
so I am
speaking that and hopefully we have made
and you will help me make a meaningful
compromise we already have a 300t
setback on lakes
for twers skis jet skis so this is
nothing new 300 ft is easily
definable is it the ultimate answer on
this
no we need to have people use some
common sense we need to have
people work to protect the
environment
and would like to to see this bill
pass as a compromise For What
legislation is when you come to this
house you try to find a reasonable
balance I think that the 300 foot is a
reasonable balance it's not going to
deny anybody the ability to to wake
surve and more importantly we are not
Banning an
activity I have a lot of friends that
have wake boats and I hope that they
will continue to be able to use them and
I hope that the Lakes will remain clear
and without being overrun by
cyanobacteria Zebra
muscles and other Aquatic species that
are dragged up so I have moved the
adoption of wherever it
is House Bill Amendment
20241 1598 and I ask you all to consider
this as not being bullied into something
okay thank you all right
uh I I I gave you the courtesy of not
interrupting you but you do need a
second for this so you're going to have
to do that all over
again no well okay uh thank you for for
a second representative La montain I
recognize for a second you wish to speak
to your
second yes I
do yes I I think 200 a 200 foot setback
is makes is going to make very little
difference in protecting water water
quality which is why well I wouldn't say
it's why the Marine industry supports it
but it it's very little sacrifice for
them and I feel that to
adopt this um bill without the
amendment is telling the Marine service
industry and everyone else that they
don't need to compromise
further I think 300 feet is a reasonable
compromise and I think we must do
something about this to protect our
lakes and that has to be a higher
priority than the recreational interest
of a few people to enjoy their sport
when it damages the water quality it
makes it harder for other people to
enjoy the lake just by swimming or on a
paddle board or a
kayak and I think we need to go for the
300 foot setback and continue to argue
for
that you know as it as it goes back to
the as it goes to the house floor and
the Senate and to the governor's desk
that we need to do the right thing and
not be pressured into passing this bill
without an amendment that basically does
nothing additional 100 feet would do
nothing so let's make an actual step
forward to have some restrictions on
this sport that can cause so much damage
I mean does anyone really think making
an ocean wave in a
lake it's fall freshwater lake is not
going to cause huge environmental
impacts of course it does so let's do
the right
thing anyone wish to speak on the
amendment representative Derby thank you
Mr chair oh sorry excuse me I
representative Bale first no she asked
first I'm mistake no I representative
bail first then representative
Darby thank you um we took extensive
testimony on this bill and um I agree
with my colleague representative lontine
the 200 fet is just not enough and we
heard in testimony that if we P you know
we should pass this bill that it's going
to put the matter to rest but I don't
think that that's really what's going to
happen I think we had two house bills
they went to the floor they didn't get
argued the way that we hoped that they
would and we didn't get a chance to
flesh out all the
details in front of the body so when we
look at this and we try to come down
there with our own position where our
position is not 200
feet so that's why I'm going to be
voting in favor of the amendment and I'm
going to just help um just
the shorelines don't recover from this
kind of energy when a wave is created
there is energy going out across a lake
however far that wave has to go before
it hits the friction is where the energy
is going to keep on going and so when it
hits that Shoreline and that Shoreline
takes the energy when it hits an animal
when it hits a um a nesting bird a kayak
that person is going to feel that energy
and that impact and that's one sport and
we have a lake full of people trying to
have um community recreation and try to
all recreate in the same space together
so those are the reasons basically that
I think we should go ahead and pass this
amendment and I'm asking everyone to
support the amendment thank
you representative Darby for comment
thank you Mr
chair we know that wake surfing can
impact act Lake quality and Wildlife how
do we know because the Senate Bill tells
us so that's why it uh indicates that
the best practice is to direct wake
waves away from the shoreline we know
because the water sports industry
Association tells us not to wake surf in
shallow water we know because New
Hampshire Dees tells us that increasing
the buffers the further away you get
from the shore the less risk there is to
to the Shoreline that we also know
um from Dees that wig surfing in shallow
water under 20 ft can increase the
phosphorus load up to 20% Which um
contributes to cyanobacteria blooms and
lengthen Bloom blooms in
progress our our fellow um there are not
many uh uh States in this nation that
are blessed with the natural lakes that
New Hampshire
has four of them are actively taking
action to um to increase the buffers for
wake surfing our direct neighbors both
Maine and Vermont have already done that
with a 500 foot 20 uh 500 foot setback
20 foot minimum depth and Main with a
300 foot uh setback 15 foot minimum
depth the Michigan Department of Natural
Resources which is equivalent to our
department of environmental uh uh
Services did a comprehensive well quoted
um
study over 50 sources and found and
their analysis was that 500 feet with a
15 uh off setback with a 15 foot minimum
depth is
required so our peers our Pier states
with natural lakes which by like I said
is not the majority of the states in
this nation are are taking action
because they know the the they know the
risk to our
Lakes we've heard of the study
referenced by uh the Marine trades
Association it's very interesting to
note that that study was produced after
the Wake responsibility campaign that uh
that promoted a 200 foot setback which
was initially promoted in uh
2018 it's also interesting to note that
if you read that study which I've read
they tell you that the own authors claim
that it's impossible to um gauge weight
wave height more than 100 F feet using
the techniques that they're using and
it's been it's been repudiated by
numerous
experts like my colleagues have said 300
fet is a meaningful setback it is um
it's recognized by voters it is
consistent with our neighboring state
for those for those folks that both boat
in multiple states it is recog it's
already trained um by to Department of
uh safety in terms of recognizing the
300 foot setback because of the ski
craft regulations and the fact the
reality is is most boers cannot
determine distinguish 200 foot off U
distance versus 150 foot distance on an
open body water that's a very difficult
to do on an open body water so what's
going to happen is this bill will act
without the amendment will have zero
impact and there thereby it's worse than
passing without the amendment it's worse
than passing nothing because we're
acting like we're doing something but
voters won't be able to act on
it Department of Environmental Services
um at my request conducted an analysis
of the lakes in New Hampshire um that
where wake surfing would be uh permitted
um with a 200 foot setback and a 50 foot
acre minimum uh a 50 acre minimum and a
300 foot setback and a 50 acre minimum
you'll see those are um if you're
interested they're in the bottom of this
paper I as though you'll see that
there's only five Lake difference for
those lakes that um do not have um
horsepower or speed limit or wake
restrictions of those five four of them
actually have less than two acres um
with a uh with a wake surfing area with
a 200 foot setback and one of them
doesn't have an adequate boat launch um
you'll see that um of the average
operational size with a 300t setback is
259 Acres 259 Acres which is larger than
the vast majority of of public water on
this on this Lake if you're
interested I have um with the help of
the lake stied production Association
charted out the 300t offset on a number
of different lakes throughout the state
these are lakes that were brought up in
testimony both on Senate Bill 431 and
Senate and House Bill 1390 where people
are actually we surfing with they want
to wake surf um and you'll see that the
the dark blue line indicates the area
that would be restricted from wake
surfing that tiny dark blue line you can
also see the very large space that it
where wake surfing is still
permitted I've put the um with again
with the um Department of Environmental
Services um support I've put the a the
acreage that would be available on these
Lakes of various sizes
um and you can see that even Lake mum
has 237
Acres I am a member of the public water
access Advisory Board and I take that
responsibility to provide access to
public Waters in New Hampshire
seriously I also cherish um our
beautiful iconic lates and I would urge
you to vote Yes on uh Amendment 1598 to
protect the Lakes thank
you anyone else else wish to speak on
the
amendment thank you Mr
chair I feel it's important to give um
the opposite side of this
debate I also read all the reports and
um I'm still uh be Twix with the
comments and the reports that talk about
real Shoreland uh harm done by wind ice
weather as compared
to moving the line 300 ft
out I give Credence that there's other
factors that hurt the shore the other
elephant in the room that some people
did mention earlier so I'll bring it up
is although it may be an incremental
small incremental increase to go from
150 to 200 it's an increase when I look
at bills and I look at the Senate the
house and the governor I try to say what
can we do with baby steps to get things
passed I am not confident that this
Amendment added on to this bill will do
anything to help this bill pass all the
house and the Senate and the governor so
I I'm always of the opinion I'd rather
take a baby step to do some help than to
pass something that may not have
likelihood of full Passage so I'm going
to vote against the amendment uh I
support the Marine trades that say 200
feet and there's nothing that prohibits
us at another uh session to come back
and increase it if we need to but uh on
practicality I I'm going to support
something that I think will pass
everyone thank you Mr
chair representative har Harvey bu
representative harb said it um what I
was going to say
thanks any of
for a second
time well thank you for offering me the
opportunity wait a minute wait a minute
she actually beat you you got to raise
your hand and and you and how's the
Water by the way I don't have a bar of
soap so I'm would you like would you
like an umbrella representative W
you turn off your mic representative
will
well I will say again that passing it at
two 200 feet is not a baby step because
it basically does nothing but with
regard to comparing the waves from the
Wake boats to the naturally occurring
storms there's a really big difference
we can do nothing about the storms
coming but they don't happen all summer
long all day long in every
direction the Wake
boats their way waves they may say oh
we're going to try to direct our wakes
away from the shore but that's almost
impossible are they only going in One
Direction no they have to turn around
multiple times so the
loons that would naturally nest and
areas that are sheltered from the
prevailing wind have no protection when
you have these wake waves coming in all
directions every day all summer long so
we do need to do something about the
things that we can control to protect
the Leakes and 200 ft is we might as
well do nothing so I don't know why we
would fight for that as if it's an
accomplishment when it's not so I'm
going to vote for the
amendment representative wolf then rep
representative
Donley thank you Mr
chairman I guess I'm more concerned
about the
future and really concerned about the
future I've seen what's
happened 15 or 18 years ago when a golf
course was being
built and the erosion control didn't
work and my daughter came out of the
lake sunp covered in brown mud it was on
channel 9 and it was on front page of
the
newspapers so I have to look at the
environment and at the same time I don't
want to affect anybody's livelihood I
have a lot of friends who have wake
boats and I'm not going to ban them and
I don't think I am going to affect the
sales of the Marine trades Association
because they're calling it a ban this is
not a ban this is in everybody's
interest to protect the future so that
they can sell more boats so that we can
go out on the lakes and I think it's
time
that we didn't chase the almighty dollar
and looked to what the environment calls
for representative
Donnelly thank you Mr chair um so I have
many constituents as well who would like
to see something uh changed and um based
on what I've heard um and talking to
colleagues across the Senate the house
um the 200 set back will work I believe
that this is an education issue as much
as we want to pass bills um I live on a
lake the last thing I want to do is
create contention amongst Our Lake
friends and by just passing bills
without any education to them and
without any Marine Patrol to help guide
this we're by doing the 300 foot rule
you're creating a problem where it's not
going to actually
pass in the long run but if we we do the
200 foot we have people saying they're
willing to do more education they're
willing to put more information out
there for everyone who has a wake
Bol wouldn't we want to pass something
that actually brings about more
education versus
legislation rep
representative uh you've spoken um
already oh representative rung has not
spoken then recognize representative
after representative rung then
representative Vale thank you Mr chair
although with this bill I'm glad to see
the distance from Shore and wake boats
the impact wake boats have being brought
to our attention but this is an issue
that as a scientist that we I I feel we
need to respect the science and the
science says 200 is not protective it's
not going to make a
difference I respect representative
harb's comments but I think doing
something just for political expediency
um when it flies in the face of sound
science is not what we should be doing I
don't think that I can look my
constituents on babus lake in the face
um or my neighbors up at Lake kosaka in
the face by saying oh we passed a bill
that increases it to 200 because it's
not going to do anything and I I feel
like we're really
disrespecting um
valid Foundation valid facts that we
should be using to drive our
decisionmaking not being driven by what
may pass or what the governor may do I
think we have to defend what's right and
what's scientifically valid and if that
takes more political courage than
letting something easily pass and I
think we need to do that thank
you representative Veil
thank you
um so as I said before we spent a lot of
time on this issue and I just think that
if we were to pass this bill as it is
without the amendment that we wouldn't
be doing what we should be doing as a
committee um and I also want to say that
you know we are the legislature we are
not living with the people who are in
this conflict every day I know that some
of the members of this committee have a
lake life and they understand the direct
impacts because they're being directly
impacted and some of people you know
have the opposite position as well but
we come in here to hear bills and to
listen to the laws as they are written
and figure out how they should be
changed and brought forward we're not
here to make a decision that everybody's
going to go away and say this bill is
what we want wanted and we're going to
rest with this bill we don't want that
rest necessarily this is really is not
progress for our committee and it is
really not our job to make
decisions that have ramifications that
really don't benefit the situation thank
you anyone else wish to speak on the mo
on the motion on the on the amendment
representative mq thank you Mr chairman
just a couple quick comments um I think
we need to show the courage to
collaborate with the other body and act
on this bill and promote a
responsible wake wake responsible
program that's won awards nationally we
need to get something done instead of
arguing over 30 yards we all have
opinions on exactly which science is the
best which distance is the best
and I don't want us to face the reality
that we've done nothing to satisfy all
of the pleas as we head into the summer
season from the folks who are fortunate
enough to live on lakes and have a lake
life or a lake house and those who are
fortunate enough to have wake craft and
wake boats we've got to act now and not
risk the death of this important
legislation we've heard from hundreds
and hundreds of wake boat owners on both
sides that have made imp passion pleased
to make something happen we had two
other bills that both wound up on the
table for whatever reason and I agree
they didn't get debated by the full body
properly but they did get debated
repeatedly they're being debated again
here we had hearings in rep's Halls we
had numerous hearings here as a full
committee as uh I don't recall whether
we had a subcommittee but we've had
numerous sessions here here's an
opportunity for us to collaborate
amongst ourselves and put 30 yards and
see what happens for the first year and
and and put it on the books that this
committee this house and this and the
full legislative General Court wants to
promote responsible wake surfing and if
200 F feet isn't enough maybe it does
need to be 300 ft next next session and
that can change and we can collect that
data and we can come back and say see it
didn't make a difference and I'm willing
to accept that perhaps after a Year's
worth of data it
didn't that's possible I'm conflicted on
the science there's a science on both
sides for sure I think some of it is
pretty good some of it is you know
everybody has an opinion on it I I think
every study can be looked at from a
variety of reasons um but I hate to
single out one type type of activity or
one type of vote when we are so close to
passing something and the other
representatives from my district have
heard it from those Lakes big and small
I I'm concerned that we will be
effectively Banning by implementing this
buffer which is what it is it's a buffer
not a b which is a good thing so I urge
the committee to take what may be 2/3 of
a loaf and 30 yards short of of what
some perceive as the the ultimate goal
line let's take this as a good way to
lead a good way to collaborate and wake
responsibly and we might have to add
another 30 yards in 12 months time or
you know what could be a short period of
time after we have some more data let's
let's take
it anyone else wish to speak on the on
the
amendment I gotta say something
been in this business now for the last
years and one of the
Prime thing things I've seen over the
years is what a very useful technique
was called a salami technique where you
take a take what you can get take the
win rather than continue to to up your
bet and eventually take a loss Lo all
right now this this amendment will give
you a
loss bill on the bill that we're
debating gives you a win it's not the
big win but it's a
win and that's
psychology so that the winning
psychology you will move be able to move
get the rest of the salami if you use
the salami technique but that's what
in front of you the the Senate is not
going to be not going to back down on
this and I don't and knowing the
governor I doubt very much that he will
either
so yes you'll get you'll feel really
good and you can tell people I voted for
ft and what happened you
lost or you can go 200 ft take the off
ER come back next year with the next
with the next for the next piece of
salami
anyway that's all I got to say any uh
anyone else wish to speak on the on the
uh the
amendment anybody want to any salami
afterward go for a
sandwich at which Cas uh will the clerk
on the amendment please call the role
thank you on Amendment
1598 representative harp
no representative GS
no representative Horgan no CL votes no
representative Healey no representative
wolf
yes representative Miku
no representative Donnelly
no representative dun no repres restive
veale yes representative run yes
representative Hamlet yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby
yes representative Howard yes
representative L montine yes
representative lit yes represent of
orgon yes and the chair
no I
that is 11 to n passes
okay
now now we have before the for the body
ought to pass as
amended uh this is obviously I mean this
I've I've never run into this before I
presume uh as your representative mchu
would probably want
to uh look for correct The Minority
Report will be ought to pass right but
we have we haven't see but does someone
wish to accept the take the
responsibility
for ought to pass as amended the
representative representative Darby
thank you Mr chair yes I'd like to make
the motion of aop pass I mean I'm I'm
I'm on territory that I've have never
had to have do this before but I could
understand that you know you're you're
you would well let's get let let's take
a vote thank you he move we need a
second
pardon great um I'm just do we now vote
on art to there there is a motion of art
to pass on the floor ought to pass as
amended as amended right what I'm trying
to do is get get it to the the so that
the person putting the uh putting forth
the motion of art to pass really wants
the mo the motion of art to pass it's
representative Wolf's
Amendment you're really trying to work
on me
I'm I think we have the motion on the
floor is ought to pass as amended right
and she second and she
second who made the motion
representative dby made the motion pass
is amended representative Veil seconded
y so that's what's on the that's what's
on the floor hey you wish any other
issue representative wolf are you you
you you look
concerned yeah I don't know what
happened to the original ought to pass
motion but if you say this is the way to
go no no I the motion the original
motion ought to pass as
amended original ought to pass motion is
now ought to pass as amended just
uh just looking for a person
who would adapt it to be to be able to
uh speak to
it Mr chair even though representative
MCU made the OTP motion it was the
amendment was passed he's not beholden
to have to write the committee report
representative Darby could write the
committee the majority report no I made
the motion of want to pass so yeah
will I will own that motion as well as
the committee report that goes with that
motion okay I see thank right this but
this is aop pass as amended will be uh
owned by representative Darby will you
wish to speak on your motion thank you
Mr chair very briefly I've already said
everything that I really want to say um
except that I um want to just repeat
this is a meaningful compromise
um and I urge the body the uh committee
to support the oop pass as amended to
show that we support clean lakes in New
Hampshire we us to speak on your
second I think we've covered everything
thank
you does anyone wish to speak on the
motion of ought to pass as
amended seeing
none clerk please call the rooll
yes um I to pass as Amendment uh as
amended Representative harb
no representative GS no representative
Horgan no cler votes no representative
Healey no representative
wolf
yes representative MCU
no representative Donnelly no
representative dun no representative Vil
yes representative Rong yes
representative Hamlet
yes representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
Howard yes representative lontine yes
representative lit yes representative
forgan yes and the
chair no it's 11 to9 motion
passes 11 to9 motion pass pass es
consent
no so so there obviously will be a
Minority Report would be a Minority
Report and the
Q all
right that closes the hearing
on this bill Senate Bill 431
uh we have some other business don't go
away I'm going to pass these
out
uh take
half
and take have just gave me one okay all
right and then
on this
again
okay all right okay all right got we
we've got two bills that have been
returned from the
Senate looking for concur non-c concur
or non-c concur PR the committee of
conference uh coming down is two side by
sides that the committee researcher has
put together in very short notice and we
need one we need two more uh two two
more uh probably uh should come
around we got him
Jim I've got exra
one got oh I
does she has an extra one if you need
it
y yeah the
uh how
we which you're doing first uh well well
we'll do
uh one I have in my hand there 39
398 the uh all you got to do is easy
most of us have read these just look
back at they where it says notes that
really tells you where the change is and
uh on
398 it looks like all it says is Senate
version removes home from home buyers
uh was that this that was
Theo I know
uh we wish to speak on it so
representative represent well
representative run had her hand okay no
I
um I I support concurrence on this bill
because they're just taking out the word
home
yep representative Derby representative
I um thank you Mr chair I did speak with
the realtors association on this and the
language uh removing home and just
saying buyers is consistent with um El
um the other notifications that are used
um and uh and broadens the you know this
the recommendation um for property for
people purchasing property so I
definitely recommend
concurrence senil just to recommend
concurrence looks like I can I could say
have unanimous concurrence of the
uh
committee course somebody else has a has
an issue uh on the next
one is 1060 relative to establishing a
geologic uh geologic
resources committee
Senate version specifies that the member
of the public on the committee is to be
appointed by the commissioner of
Dees and the Senate version adds
language about who call the
meeting meeting should be called by New
Hampshire
July represent representative run
I support concurrence Mr chair and I'm
really I'm really bumped out that we
didn't that we missed that because we
should have caught that when it was in
our committee thank you representative
Bale I think we should concur on this as
well and thank you for having this
prepared thank me thank thank our
committee researcher who jumped right on
it thank you christe by the way i' I've
asked her that don't don't wait for me
to ask immediately do these because
these are these do
work
and this this is a chance I was able
to get us uh so I think any other
concerns or comments or questions concur
on this one as
well Mr chair
yes I does the bottom of page two they
that it's appointed by the commissioner
of
Dees those the added
words yes okay take it
back okay all right we concur everyone
concurs I can get these into the into
the
clerk now unfortunately I got to write I
I have to get up and speak on
it you did
we all con we all coner all right thank
you very much any other business we
should do before we begin before we adj
Mr chairman yep Mr chairman I had
suggested uh if the members of the
committee are agreeable I thought we
might do a group picture on the front
over here of all of us on the committee
and we can have The Replacements join us
too if they wish but uh this may be the
last time the committee meets um in
session this year so I thought a group
picture would be nice for you as a
momento we could pass it around
absolutely thank
you Jody will volunteer to take the
picture yes
thank
okay let me let me make certain let me
end the make make certain that we're
we're
ended all right we're definitely
ended
e e